so to start here I think you have some
of the absolute best co-stars in this
movie so can you tell me one thing about
canateo and one thing about woomi's
approach to their work that feels
uniquely them that you really
appreciated or admired oh my gosh yeah
um I I couldn't agree more I do I was
blessed with like the most brilliant
co-stars in this movie um God women is
um she is as a human being like she when
people talk about like somebody lighting
up a room that's absolutely her
um and yeah she was really thoughtful
um and like really wanted to
um
like feel every inch of like not only
what her character Sophie was going
through but what everybody in the room
is going through she's playing someone
who's like really empathetic and
sensitive and you know can kind of see
can see what's going on
um more so than any other character in
the film and
um like energetically watching her get
to that place was really really cool and
um I've said many times that I'm like
obsessed with her I followed her around
set like a baby bird like she's so cool
such a badass and
um she had she in her in that kind of
badass kind of DOA she would just kind
of like
um be very very pragmatic you know like
they were really on opposite ends of the
Spectrum in terms of the way that they
worked and
um I remember at one point uh we were in
a van heading to set and I think woomi
was like guys should we sing songs and
um the first person to guess which song
it is like wins we'll make a little game
and ganyadia was like oh my God you're
such a theater kid you know she was just
like so
um uh like stoic and sarcastic and funny
and
um yeah they actually like seemed to
have
um in the way that they were like kind
of opposite ends of the spectrum as
people it was similar in terms of how
they approached the work and they think
they actually ended up the closest
um out of everybody on the film which I
loved like they couldn't be more
different and they like went away with
this incredible friendship it does not
surprise me to hear that perfect fits
for their particular roles I also wanted
to touch on the producing that you're
doing more and more of now and I was
wondering is there any particular past
project where you notice that itch to
produce first start to creep in where
you know maybe there was something about
the way the set was run that made you
think like you know I have a better way
to make that happen more efficiently oh
my God I feel like you're calling me
bossy and you're not wrong
um you're so bossy during our last
conversation so it was your words
um yeah I I definitely feel like
um there have been many projects where I
am you know I'm convinced that my
Approach would be better and of course
you know we all come in with our own
ideas and we're all often wrong but yes
there of course have been many times
where I'm like I wish that I had a
little bit more
um like authentic power on this set to
just maybe Implement a little bit of
um different approaches or whatever
um but I think with this one
um I was surprised I was more involved
in the
um cuts in post-production than any
other uh film before you know this the
movie is uh very personal to me so it
was important to me to get it right
every step of the way and to feel like I
had an eye on what Alice was going
through and the way that we presented it
and trusting that
um we could follow Alice's experience
and believe her I guess
um rather than leaning into showing
maybe
um Simon's Behavior as the kind of
evidence for what's going like what's
really going on in the film
um so uh yeah there were a lot of
different versions of the cut and it was
also really interesting to me to see you
know the way that like these tiny
changes in the edit really can change
the feeling
um of the film overall even though
though they're really small changes when
you think about it oh my I have to
imagine that experience is going to come
in handy big time as you see through
your directorial debut actually speaking
of that I'll jump there next because the
last time we spoke you talked a lot
about the pressure to you know feel as
though you were making the folks behind
the monitor go like yeah we got it with
with your bag of tricks and you know
having worked on some of your
directorial debut at this point I was
wondering have you figured out maybe a
better way to give your cast positive
reinforcement but also without making
them chase it like that oh that's
interesting yeah
um I actually was surprised by like the
first thing that comes to mind is I
think a lot of the
um like uh producers
um were surprised by the amount of stuff
that I was doing with the actors in the
film where I think a lot of filmmakers I
I don't know like if whether it was in a
program they went to or whatever but
that they I think there's a lot of bad
rumors going around about what you can
and can't say to actors
um so I there was a lot of stuff that I
would just you know talk about with
actors that
um that people were like I didn't know
you were allowed to do that or I thought
that was something you weren't supposed
to do like it's weird we're sort of like
treated as these um both like as like
insane divas and as like these delicate
little eggshells so
um it's uh it sometimes you're like just
just tell me to like clench my jaw like
you know like if it's like everything's
working but like right at the end just
clench your jaw and then we're good
um great you know
um and equally there are scenes where
it's like I'm just gonna give you all
the space that you need and we're gonna
go until you're happy and
um and like I think that both of those
things are valid for a whole movie and a
whole performance so
um yeah that was that was a really
fascinating thing to me that
um that so many people uh were like oh I
didn't know you were allowed to talk to
actors like that
um because I do think that there's like
a rumor going around that we are
um basically crazy children which is not
not true we're barely people but
um yeah I thought that was interesting I
mean we're all on this side basically
children also so I kind of get it
um going back to your your personal you
know bag of tricks that you had
mentioned what what is one tool in that
bag of tricks that you found most
difficult to let go of but then also
what is a new tool that you now have in
that bag of tricks that is useful that
you know you can credit to Alice darling
Oh that's interesting
um I mean I guess there's not like
specific things it's not like
um uh
yeah I guess I can't think of um
like an a great example but I do kind of
know the feeling in the air when it's
like oh I know what I I know what
they're looking for and it's you know
like a moment where when I'm looking at
that character my eyes kind of light up
and when I'm looking at that character
um you know I I look sort of forlorn or
something it's you know it's like just
sort of reading like what they what
somebody wants out of you and I know how
to kind of fake that thing for them and
to actually trust that I know what the
experience is and I know
um what it felt like and it and that and
that I can like access that in my body
now and put it on camera and not
actually get caught up in what the
people behind the camera want was
um like a really great exercise in
self-trust this movie is like bottled up
all that confidence you would ever need
to have self-trust in yourself you're so
good in this movie I cannot wait to see
the movie you're directing
congratulations thank you